Probably all of you once planned the
clean up activities.
And you can imagine I also planned one
weekend to
clean up of my basement.
And I just uh went there
uh and went to clean up all of the stuff
there. You know, throw up uh old washing
machine.
And
I just look at the corner there
and realized there's something weird
there
lying on the floor.
So, I just grab it, look at the
the strange device looks a bit familiar,
but a bit
old like from '80s
with keyboard
but with a weird displays. Of course,
covered with dust.
I just take it to my hand.
Look at it.
And I was completely surprised
that um
device have a shell.
And it's on.
So,
um I used my superpowers skills in a
terminal
and I asked I provided there
a simple question.
Who am I?
And the device responds in the weirdest
way I couldn't imagine.
In the natural way language.
So, the story I just described to you
it can be a great story for a marketing.
But
honestly, um
I just wanted to build a device
which is physical and AI native
like
the device which comes from the future.
Hello.
My name is Lech Kalinowski.
I hold a PhD in physics
and today I want to present you
a device and uh
backend and a system I built over last
couple of months.
And the whole story begins because I
just simply wanted to build
a remote controller to my open claw
instance on my DJX park.
And um
the story
is simple.
Because when you are just first think
about the
LLMs, then you're not thinking about the
audio, about the generative uh
generative uh videos or pictures. First,
you're thinking about the text.
And then I just get the bright idea that
maybe I can use some kind of
better display to read and type
with my LLM.
Of course, on the market, there is a
electronic paper,
but um I realized electronic paper can
be a bit slow. Of course, it's perfect
for reading,
but if you just want to provide
dynamically text to it, you proba-
probably need uh
faster display.
And then
I just uh used and uh in my design
uh a simple
connection
of the OLED display, the small one, one
color,
with the electronic paper display.
And then
with this
simple, let's say, dual display
approach, I realized I can build quite a
powerful and energy-efficient terminal
to
play
with my
claw.
And um
of course, behind it
uh there is uh some kind of lot of
complications.
Because from one side, I just wanted to
build a remote control, but from other
side
there is such a niche on the market
and this is the AI-native operational
systems.
And when I just started to think
more clearly about it
I just realized I can build such a
system for my
purposes.
But not with a super powerful powerful
computers, but with a small
microcontrollers.
And I just designed a system
a built in let's say with a
with a say uh
four classes.
One is the internal shell to
control the terminal itself, you know,
system settings,
basic configurations, Wi-Fi connection.
And within my idea to build an AI-native
device
I build an assist control
and uh
one thing which really surprised me and
what I will explain you later, RPG mode.
And uh
here it is.
I started to prototype
DGX Park at the
um at the
background here on the picture, two
displays.
One it's a live surface, that means the
dynamic part. You can type the whole
text provided is
written there. And when you adjust
trigger action, hit enter,
then the whole render also happens on
the
second bistable electronical
paper.
But
there is a lot of complications and lot
of tech and lot of steps you need to do
to get an clear user experience and
clear interface.
So, I just found out a lot of the
different approaches how to render
properly on the two
displays properly
render the the the the interface. I just
interact to control my LLMs and to get
in responses and to do whatever I want
with my DGX park through the through the
open claw.
And this is the one of the approaches
that you can just
have fixed static buffers and render
one-bit images
stored in the
in the memory. That means
the pages live in a pre-allocated
memory. There's a no markdown engine
and no malloc on the
MCU
side.
I just wanted to really to show you how
the system is really complicated here.
And this is
not because I just
wanted to use that much components. It's
because there is a huge need to build a
to build a power
management system
because I just blow up two these place
over my prototype build.
And um
I just
needed to be sure
that the current and the voltage is
stable as possible.
So, here inside you have an MCU, which
is ESP32 dual-core microcontroller. Here
you have an OLED display, keyboard, and
an encoder. And of course,
the mention
um power supply.
But, the A native end-to-end device is
not uh
let's say that simple because of the,
you know, high power consumption and the
and the hunger for the compute
capabilities of your device.
So, here is a full backend
created. That means I just created a
full backend and here's the presented
architecture of it.
That first we have a vault firmware
deployed
on the on the terminal, and there's a
huge backend, which um handle all of the
all of the agentic work with the open
claw
and handle the LLM. I just want to point
out here um
within my today's presentation, I just
want to demonstrate you
um
the device connected
to an
open-source GPT 120 billion parameters
model.
Um and I just serve that model with a
let's say most possible optimal way
using
and I I I use their TensorRT
serving system.
And I just exposed OpenAI style to uh
also like LLM proxy because I just hit a
lot of walls with uh
other open source models
um because that's not all models match
the style of the Open AI API.
Um
as I said uh the first idea was to
build and
mhm play with the Open Claw through that
terminal and this is the stuff I just
do with this. Here you can look at the
picture and see an example. I was I was
possible to hit a command like write a
Java example
uh and store it on my local machine
and Open Claw with the with the LLM
support just did
work and make it happened.
Okay, and here's my field notes, the
things that doesn't go as expected.
Uh lessons learned.
Uh first of all the uh software I2C
and because I just wired up things there
and it doesn't work correctly.
Um
and there's a way to um to do proper
control over over I2C without any
additional physical pull-ups mounted.
From other side GPIO 13
um there's a silent failure. Uh there
was a need to move to the other port.
Um
to um to be sure that everything works
correctly.
From other side
I need to build up the regulator
the power supply
um the whole unit of the power supply
um because the the regulator
uh kills the LED and and fragile parts
of the display
and cost me a lot of time and
and
getting the
replacement parts from the market took
so long.
A couple of weeks.
And the last part, quality of your
parts, that means encoder
cheap and low quality give me a lot of
rotational noise
and there was a need to build up the the
pull-ups and to
and to
wire it up additional
capacitors there.
But
this is the funnest stuff.
My favorite one.
Because the this part really surprised
me.
You already know there's a huge part
called RPG and behind it is a bit sad
maybe story.
Because uh
I just never played RPGs game like on
the paper. That means with a with a lot
of friends. You can go to a
to apartment, you know, open a book and
make an
someone game master
and play in a real text-based
RPG.
And after a lot of those years, I just
never tried it.
But I built um
a RPG
game and a console
um which give me a pure experience of
the
text-based um RPG games, role-playing
games.
And
actually I it's a bit funny
because those device
it's really
like perfect fits for that kind of
gaming.
I build out an NPC and memory around
that. I just created the mood of the
world, the contents, omnious, and I just
used all of the, you know, the LNM um
advantages to build uh the best uh
role-playing game experience
ever.
Um I just created four different worlds.
From one side, I just wanted to build
something cyberpunk related. From other
side, I just wanted something uh
The Witcher part related, that means
some kind of fantasy world with the
dragons. But also my
favorite one is the is the void in a
deep space somewhere
um in the cosmos.
And
this is really uh
really good example how we can just use
uh generative AI to build computer
games. From one side, I just generate
the characters, their
worlds, maps, the skills, uh and all of
those converted with the mechanism I
just described at the beginning of that
presentation with the one-bit
memory allocation, that means all of the
pictures transform to the to the
matrices, to the
uh to the to the maps.
And um
one
um
important uh important thing, actually
uh
the device is really bulletproof.
Um if the LED doesn't work, you the
e-paper works. If the cardboard doesn't
work, that means the keyboard,
uh
then you'll you have an encoder.
Wi-Fi falls, you always can use your uh
local uh shell.
Um
And um
funny stuff,
the
area of the intellectual property there.
I just uh do some kind of research in
the field
and everyone just wants to build the
devices around the audio interfaces, the
video capture, you know, but for the
quiet places, when you just want to, you
know, sit down, keep calm, and play your
RPG game,
you don't need any of the, you know,
colorful, powerful displays, you know,
all of these, you know, popping up with
the colors and all of the distractions,
commercials, web pages, and other
things. Sometimes you just want to sit
down
and you know, do do the right job with
the with the with the open claw or or or
you know, just chat with your LLM, read
and write in the quiet environment
without any of the
distractions. And there's a niche on the
market.
So, I also
decided to build a the provisional
patent here in that field
and maybe it will bring some
commercial device in the future to a
to a market.
Some numbers.
In my project
I just pushed
130 comments around 3 months of work.
Two deep displays.
Each of the display do other job.
Four modes.
For worlds, for gaming.
In general, 16 classes.
That means you can generate RPG worlds
inside of it.
Firmware is is really tiny, really
small, and it works extremely fast.
And everything is powered by one single
polymer cell.
Lithium polymer cell.
But maybe
some remarks and takeaways. Much of this
place to the job.
Uh there's a plenty of them on the
market.
Keep the model of the metal
because
it's really heavy. That means for now we
don't have such a models which runs
really on the super tiny MCUs.
In in means LLMs.
And try narrative narrative. The context
matters
and in general not
numbers.
So here I also record a the demo, the
usage, how the device work and some kind
of
uh some kind of um last
um last session.
Um please enjoy.
And I will place a
couple of comments there.
Device is booting. Connecting to a local
Wi-Fi network.
Here's the welcome screen
and the main screen.
Small display.
Keyboard
first simple
help command.
Here you will have all of the things you
can do with the device.
There's also a tutorial for gaming and
tutorial for
the device itself.
And when you just switch it on for the
first time, then you need to or can go
you don't have to, but you can go
through the
tutorial itself to learn how to use it.
Usage of the Open Claw agent, that means
right now I'm just checking my DGX
Spark.
And want to look at the disk space.
Here's that.
Let's maybe now look on the
my favorite
part
with gaming.
>> For worlds
Older guns, neon abyss
The hollows
and the void witch.
You can select your mm
your character.
And L and just generates the
stuff. Everything is generated there.
Um pictures,
uh
uh personalities of the of the people.
And here, there's a mood. There's a
breach. You're in the deep space and
can't
deep dive into the other world.
Yeah.
>> So, that's it.
That was the the video. Funny part is
that
the game like this
without the three-dimensional graphics
use the most advanced Nvidia uh
processor
mounted in the DGX Park that means the
the the this is the bug and currently I
just prepare for the demonstration.
And so, the quiet game
with the you know, text interface
requires the the
most powerful computer
computer graphics card in the in the
world.
And maybe another thing is that the
presentation was about the handle device
to control
uh agent and open close
with the local LLMs, but in general, it
was about the Game Boy.
The device to
to play with
LLMs.
Thank you for the attention thank you
very much for the
for the Kostak support because I'm just
working in at Kostak in the
technological incubator uh
and the whole work was supported by
by
Kostak company.
Thank you very much.